First, look for someone approachable.
Start with a smile and introduction. This puts everyone at ease.
Communications expert Carol Fleming says to remember the acronym "ARE."
Anchor.
Find something you have in common. This can be something you've experienced...
...or something you're both experiencing in that moment.
Reveal.
Say something about yourself that relates to your anchor topic,...
...creating trust and providing something for them to respond to.
Encourage.
This is your time to ask a question, prompting them to respond.
Keep your questions open-ended. This allows for a more in-depth conversation.
If you're stumped for a topic, stick to easy ones like their job, hobbies and family...
...but always remember, stay away from controversial topics like politics.
A compliment works well too,...
...just be sure to transition the conversation afterward.
Some people don't know how to handle them.
Using the person's name in conversation will also yield good results.
People appreciate the special attention...
...and remember to listen. People love to talk about themselves.
Restate what you hear to show you are listening.